vanessa paradis et johnny depp ch et un
couple parfait c'est le bonheur absolu
donc on va faire une interview je fous
la merde ça avait toujours amoureuse de
johnny depp n'est toujours pas mariés
donc vous serez pas qu'il est un peu
moins bon sur moi non c'est vrai qu'il a
une vilaine verrues plantaires
c'est pas dommage d'être tout le temps
séparés dans sérieux justement n'est pas
qu ils négligent pas là non c'est caen
qui vous a dit je t'aime pour la
dernière fois les années cadeau qui vous
a fait c'est quoi si vachement
attentionné quand ils offrent des fleurs
il dit pas sa secrétaire de le faire
c'est lui qui va vraiment les achetés au
magasin il n'oublie jamais votre
anniversaire celui de votre rencontre
non plus non merci mon service pour
savoir qu'il est parfois moi je vous le
confirme tout de suite et il est parti
jean gallet parfois quand même il oublie
de relever la cuvette des toilettes
non jamais non c'est un mec formidable
non seulement c'est quoi qui vous énerve
le plus chez lui ce qu'on ne fasse pas
nous il a des défauts mais je voulais
mais alors d'accord mais là il est
pardonné il laisse traîner ses
chaussettes
j'aimerais pas qui arrange toutes ces
voix si vous êtes folle de lui il a un
petit peu un tempérament de feu
ouais et qui sait pas toujours très
facile ni mais moi ça me plaît à ces
petits à l'eau vincent rottiers salut
c'est laurent battut et sur paris là il
peut passer
oui bonjour vincent 20 tonnes qui on est
à l'antenne tu es sur paris est ce que
tu veux passer s'il te plaît à la plaine
saint denis
c'est vanessa matz du nom c'est vanessa
paradis qui a parlé de toi l'addict
était formidable et je te la passe donc
même pas le cul on t'attend moi aussi je
t'embrasse je te passe vanessa à l'eau
non mais c'est toi non mais c'est mais
ouais mais je n'y suis pour rien j'ai
juste sous les 10 ans des jo d'hiver
alors alors quand en plus à devenir mais
non ils veulent que tu ne viens pas du
fabuleux
mon âge il ya plein mon nom mais il a
mieux à faire est là la fête de la
musique c'est ça c'est bien de s'en
remettre le disque à la fin y aller elle
n'est pas amoureuse de lui blâmé j'ai
beaucoup de tendresse pour les labs est
arrivé sain bien les tartuffes a sonné
samedi a pu la fête de la musique c'est
le mot qui vient à lait damné salta d'or
je serai johnny depp jeu serait jaloux
mois elle t'adore elle a vite la 18 dab
était hyper millions à la 10 9 il venait
d'avoir 18 ans elle a même chanté enfin
il dit que c'était une belle aventure
avec toi mais qui paraît minutes à nous
raconter bon en tout cas là on t'attend
je crois qu'il a passé parce que le
mettre les choses au point
[Musique]
de deux trois petites questions rivard
donc il est parfait si johnny depp
évidemment il râle pas quand il faut
descendre la poubelle non
il ad maliki vous avez quand même voilà
a quand même bien d'accord vous l'avez
déjà chopé en train de regarder un film
porno non non bon ben c'est sans espoir